انتقل الى باريس وهذه الصور المباشره
لمواجهات دائره بهذه الاثناء بين
المتظاهرين وبين الشرطه الفرنسيه سنستمع
قليلا واعود للتعليق على هذه الصور
[تصفيق]
اذا عمليات كار وكار كل يعني طيله الساعات
الماضيه بين المتظاهرين الفرنسيين وبين
قوات الامن الفرنسيه بعد هذه التظاهره
التي دعت اليها النقابات الفرنسيه وطبعا
كان هناك دعوه شعبيه كبيره للنزول الى
الشارع بما سمي الخميس الاسود
للتظاهر والاعتراض طبعا على قانون التقاعد
الذي رفعت بموجبه الحكومه الفرنسيه سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما كما اصبح
معلوم وهو محل رفض شعبي ونقابه وسياسي
طبعا خلال التاسعه سنكون مع المراسلين
وزملائنا الموجودين في باريس للحديث عن
هذه التظاهره ونقل الصوره من هناك
كمان نشاهد مشاهدينا على الشاشه الان
الحكومه الفرنسيه تقدر عدد المحتجين في
الخميس الاسود باكثر من مليون شخص طبعا
يعني بحسب الزملاء هناك كان من المتوقع ان
تكون هناك مظاهره مليونيه بجميع المناطق
الفرنسيه احتجاجا على هذا القانون على ما
يبدو ان الشارع الفرنسي لن يهدا ستبقى هذه
التظاهرات مفتوحه حتى يعني
خرق الاحداث خرق او على الاقل استجابه
الحكومه لاي مطالب طبعا الموقف الرسمي
الفرنسي كما شاهدنا بالامس بمقابله الرئيس
الفرنسي ما زالت عند حاله هو يعتبر بان
هذا التشريع ضروره وبان لا عوده عليها
طبعا تطورات الساعات المقبله ممكن ان تغير
شيء ما خصوصا ان هناك اصرار نقابي وشعبي
على احداث حاله من الشلل كما اصبح معلوم
بالقطاعات الاساسيه في الداخل الفرنسي وهو
ما سيضرر اكثر طبعا الاقتصاد الفرنسي الذي
هو اصلا متضرر بفعل كل الازمه الاخيره
الاقتصاديه بالدول الاوروبيه والحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
اعد واذكر بان هذا التشريع مرر بدون
العوده الى مجلس النواب بسبب عدم وجود
اغلبيه لايمن القوى هناك وبسبب خوف
الحكومه من تطيييره داخل الوقت مجلس
النواب طبعا هذا ما اثار ايضا سخط شعبي
كبير بانه تم تمريره يعني فتوى دستوريه
بدون اراده الشعب وبدون موافقه الشعب
الفرنسي عليه
اليسار الفرنسي النقابات طبعا الممثله
باليسار واقصى اليمين واليمين كل الاحزاب
تقريبا ضد هذا التشريع
وطبعا طلبوا الحكومه بالاستقاله طلبوا عدد
كبير من المسؤولين بالرجوعا ولكن على ما
يبدو حتى الساعه بان لا استجابه لا حكوميه
ولا رئاسيه
للمطالب الشعبيه
[تصفيق]
اذا هذه التظاهره التي
سميت بالخميس الاسود هي تاتي ضمن سلسله
التظاهرات بدات منذ اسابيع في جميع
المناطق الفرنسيه وهي تصعيديه بكل جمعه
يعني الناس نشاهد الاعداد تكبر اكثر فاكثر
مع تعنت الحكومه هناك تعنت شعبي بان لا
خروج من الشارع قبل استجابه الحكومه وجهات
الرسميه الفرنسيه للمطالب الشعبيه التي
تطالب الرجوع عن القانون الذي اصبح معلوم
هو قانون التقاعد الذي عدل سن التقاعد من
62 عاما الى 64 عاما